hey this is Sarah with registered nurse
Orion calming and today I want to show
you how to administer a so
innama many times in the hospital your
patient will be ordered some type of
enema there's different types are split
Intimus there's KX lait enemas or soap
suds enemas just to name a few
today I'm going to show you how to do
the soap suds enema here we have our bag
this is about a thousand milliliter bag
I filled it up to about the 500
milliliter part and I have filled it
with warm water whenever you're filling
your bag you'll want to check the
temperature with your forearm just to
make sure it's not too hot not too cold
you want it warm and you'll fill it up
to the prescribed amount the doctor
usually writes how much to give and
you'll be putting in side of it it comes
with a packet of soap side and you'll
mix it up and what we'll do is we will
insert this this is the part of the end
of a bag that will go inside the rectum
and you'll slowly release this fluid
into the rectum our goal is to cleanse
the rectum from any part of the stool
that's built up or just to get the
ballast clean a lot of patients are
order this before surgery but in most
cases it's ordered for a patient who's
experiencing um constipation so to do
this she'll get your supplies you'll
make sure soap suds enema and you'll get
your patient always explained to your
patient while you're doing with this
procedure and if you have someone who
can help you of course get help with
this as well so get your patient we have
Miss Smith or mannequin who will be
helping us with this procedure we have
her on her left side and we have her
right leg sort of bent this just helps
the fluid guide into the rectum what
you'll do is you'll take your cap off of
your bag and you lubricate this very
well because it's a hard plastic piece
and
want this to be comfortable as
comfortable as it can be whenever it's
inserted into the patient you'll hang
your bags on your IV pole and get any
towels drapes anything you need because
this procedure can get messy you also
might want to use a gown and the little
blue isolation gallons we have stocked
on the units you'll probably want to
wear one of those to help protect
yourself so what you'll do and check the
area for any hemorrhoids and you're
leading anything that you wouldn't want
to insert something like this so just
look at the area lubricate your tip you
have a clamp here and you'll want to
make sure your clamp is away from the
fluid and watch out we'll leave
sometimes and you have it lubricated and
you're going to start insert into the
rectum about three to four inches okay
always if the patient tells you that
hurts or you meet with distance stop and
you can try again
after you have inserted about three to
four inches you're going to hold your
bag about 12 to 18 inches above the
rectum and slowly let your clamp release
and let the fluid flow in warn your
patient that they may feel some pressure
cramping and if this is so stop your bag
for about 30 seconds and then start it
again a little bit slower until all the
fluid has infused into the rectum takes
a couple minutes but just take your time
and it'll be flowing in and then
whenever it's done after all your fluid
has float floating you'll take it out
and clean the area you may have a little
bit of stool on your end of the cap just
clean the area and throw away your bag
and tell the paint and cover up your
patient and tell your patient to hold
the fluid in for about five to ten
minutes and this just helps break up any
hard stool and helps get the most
effectiveness out of the enema this is
hard for a lot of patients because they
describe feeling a lot of pressure in
their bottom and so if they can't hold
it just you know get them to the
bathroom or get them on the bedpan so
after that and when every patient has a
bowel movement be sure to look at that
see how effective the enema was and see
if it has to be repeated so that is
exactly how you do a success enema and
if you liked this video or need any
other nursing skill videos please check
out our website register nurse or in
comm and thank you so much for watching